the truth is over the years i keep doing
it and the fact that i keep going back
to it means that i actually care
guido you have a quote on your facebook
i think it was from an interview that
you did
and
the quote begins with make sure you want
it
yes
i'm wondering can i continue i'll let
you know more of what you said here if
you want me to remind you so it's um
trust your own talent and the
singularity of your own voice be careful
who you listen to
and if this is what you want don't get
easily discouraged
what does that mean
make sure you want it that's fascinating
um
yeah so i know a lot of talented people
talented writers talented artists in
general but talent is only a part of the
equation i feel like in in this medium
you know it's so
competitive and so tough and it's so
hard to get people to care
your talent can only get you so far it's
important
by the way you don't have to be talented
i feel like persistence and i'm not
saying anything new here but persistence
is so much more important or as
important as talent
so creativity i feel like you can
develop it right you don't have to be
born creative you can nurture it
but there's a part of you that has has
to hustle so what you can't fake it if
you don't want it
and this applies to actors directors
writers
people can tell if you desire it and if
you don't that's totally fine
and i'm not gonna tell people what line
of work they should be in but
you can sense when someone really wants
to tell a story when someone wants to
because writing is not necessarily easy
it's
whoever tells you writing is easy
you know i suspect that statement
i'm not saying it's the hardest thing
their hardest jobs for sure but there's
something about writing that's
exhausting
because it's you know it involves an
emotional introspection
um
trying to figure out who you are what do
you want to talk about what resonates
with you what resonates with other
people
so it is draining um that's why you know
i i can only write a certain amount of
pages a day because
i want to write something that's
truthful and writing truthful pages
takes a lot of energy a lot of
thought a lot of
asking questions a lot of doubt
that's why you know i didn't mean that
quote to be daunting what i mean is
if you really want to do this then no
one can stop you
just you know
there can be failure along the way that
there can be many frustrations
i mean daily
every writer will know this you know
some days you just write great pages
some days it doesn't work some days you
write bad or bad pages or you get
rejections or you get awful notes
you know notes that you don't know what
to do with like
how am i going to apply this note and
it's a job you can't say no right
um
so what i meant is
you know if the desire is there if the
flame is within you then
you got the most important thing
how should someone
quote unquote check themselves to know
if they really want it because i think
we all think we want certain things and
then
once we go through the process day in
and day out
then it becomes clear to us what it
actually is
yeah i it's a good question
so i don't i don't intend to be a guru
of any sorts and sometimes the line is a
bit blurry between like self-help and
you know but
it is a very intimate thing you know to
me at least writing is a very intimate
thing very personal thing
even if i'm not writing about my own
life which i rarely do
it is incredibly pers i care about it
and you know there are moments of doubt
of course there were moments and there
are still moments when i wonder is this
the best way to channel my
abilities my skills my talent the truth
is over the years i keep doing it and
the fact that i keep going back to it
means that i actually care
that to me is the the best evidence that
i i am a writer this is not a hobby this
is not something that i'm good at i mean
i'm good at certain things that i don't
necessarily spend time on i don't know i
guess i could have been a good lawyer
i've thought about this many times i
would have certainly made more money i
would have been more stable my dad would
have been delighted
but that's not how it went
you know there's a creative energy
there's a need to express yourself
through stories
because i mean i've i've been a film
critic for 10 years before actually
becoming a screenwriter
and you know that's that's a long story
how i became a film critic
i don't think any child you know any
eight ten-year-old child says i want to
become a film critic right
um but it happened and i'm i'm glad it
did um
but you know being a journalist or
um
writing a film analysis which i did
that's not that's a whole different
approach it's still writing
but it's not
i mean it is creative but it's it's it's
not the same way to apply your your
emotion your brain
it's very different
so at some point i had to question
myself you know do i want to analyze a
film that's already made and out there
someone else's work or do i want to
produce my own work
and that takes courage and that takes
facing your fears and limitations and
you know it's it's really hard to write
a script
if you were an attorney presenting your
own case
so you were you were employed by guido
segal
and you were speaking to the jury about
why guido should continue
on this path
so ladies and gentlemen of the jury
i present to you my client and and he
really wants this he's not sure if it'll
ever pan out or i don't know what would
what would the argument be how would you
convince 12 jurors with their arms
crossed that
i guess what i would say is
i like a good challenge and this is the
most challenging and exciting thing that
i've found
um i don't i don't know if i could have
been a doctor in the sense that i
couldn't do the same thing over and over
and over and over again
and with writing it's always new
no script is or play i guess or novel
they're never the same
so
with practice you get better at it but
every new story
you face or you know you have to break
down
poses new a new set of
new challenges
and
that to me is very
exciting so persistence we're going back
to what you said originally that talent
necessarily
it's not always
in the
equation it's persistence
yeah i mean
and especially in a city like l.a
there's so many talented people and i
don't say this you know lightly i mean
i've met so many talented writers that
come from all over the country all over
the world
and they're here for a reason but to
make it here i mean i'm again i don't
want to be the one saying what it means
to make it i would say to get a job or
to have a several jobs that
just just to be paid to write means a
lot
i want to be very realistic of course
you need a dream we all have one or many
dreams but
i think my goal is to keep to be paid to
write and that to me is the dream it's
so maybe i've become older and jaded and
more realistic but it's so hard to get
paid to write to get paid to be an
artist a creative
um
so you have to constantly negotiate with
what the industry wants and the
standards and what you want and
it's not necessarily the same of course
when you get to a guess to a certain
point in your career that you're in
control you can decide
but still
i mean i i remember i i met paul feig
right
we did
wrote and directed bridesmaids among
ghostbusters among many other things
and i asked him
uh paul when is the right time to do
your passion project and he said never
never is the right time and you just do
it if you want but
know that it's risky
when you were in grade school or as a
teenager were you bored in school
no i actually you know i get i i was i
was a nerd um
i was very
i wasn't a troublemaker um
i actually loved um
loved school i know that's not a common
thing to say but i loved learning i
loved history
i did okay with math and physics and
chemistry you know all those subjects
but um
literature
um history
later on philosophy like i connected to
all that
you know and i love i've always loved
reading
i guess when i decided to be a filmmaker
you know and i still dream about
directing i don't know i don't think i'm
a director by nature
because i love words i work with words
and that's why
since i love films and i love literature
i'm a writer i mean and it makes so much
sense for me to be a screenwriter
but no i mean i actually love school
and grad school and you know college
was the passion project ever the right
time did you find time to make yours
or
it's still in the works well you know i
i had a tv i have a tv show that i've
developed that i've written the pilot
and it's been in development for three
years
and it's period i mean and again i don't
make it easy on myself you know it's
it's an expensive show it's period it's
about the 60s
uh chicago sorry to interrupt i won't by
the way this is the thing i i didn't set
out to be a period writer but um i guess
it's it resonates with me so i i wrote
one show that takes place in the late
60s in chicago
[Music]
that i don't think that's going to
happen by the way because they um
they're going to make the movie i think
it's about the young lords and of course
you know me not being puerto rican um
doesn't help i got very i met
um some of those historical figures i
interviewed them
um
it was really interesting but um
sometimes some things don't pan out and
you just let them go and that's you know
uh this show no the show is is uh takes
place mostly in boston in the 60s so
it's psychedelics
um
and you just gotta be patient you know
i've written that script so many times
and rewritten it and um
you know it takes time and money and
getting people attached
this is about timothy leary yes it is
okay i as growing up in san francisco
knew his name a lot and um
around interest yeah so that's um
i i adapted this author who now became
my friend robert greenfield and bob
wrote about all these figures in the 60s
like you know the grateful dead jerry
garcia and the grateful dead timothy
leary
so i adapted bob and we became friends
and he's like a mentor to me now
um
so that opened up that script
opened up other doors to writing about
you know the 60s and rock and roll and
psychedelics and
and i clearly connect even though i
wasn't born around that time i connect
to that
i felt the same way even though i'm a
gen x or so yeah but there was something
about
being there and just seeing
just the counterculture movement that
was very attractive and
yeah
you know i i
what i suspect or what i feel at least
is that um
we have an idea of those of those times
and a feeling that there was a dream of
how society could have been
um and that it didn't work out but
for you know for a few years it felt
like america at least could become place
where you know there was a certain
amount of freedom and and people were
against the vietnam war and you know
expansion of consciousness and
um and i feel like a lot of what's
happening today is still you know is the
the the effect of those of those days
like we're still we're going back to
some of the ideas and uh theories um
back in the day um i i i you know i'm
seduced by the idea of of a different
society where
everyone's welcome and you know
you have a certain amount of freedom to
do what you do as long as you don't hurt
other people
i guess that's why i go back to the 60s
or my idea of the 60s
and is that one of the reasons you said
you don't make it easy on yourself in
that doing
you know doing the time
different you know in terms of costumes
and cars and and getting the rights to
music and things like that would be a
lot certainly i mean
period by itself you can see producers
get scared
um because we're talk if it's a tv show
we're talking about at least a 2 million
dollar episode in a ten episode season
at least i'm saying right um
so it's costumes it's cars if it's based
on real people it's having vip which
which i do but
um
you know
it's more challenging um
so i i get this uh note or this comment
constantly which is why don't you write
something contemporary based on your own
story
and i usually reply to this
you know there is a lot of me in what
you read the fact that it's not
autobiographical doesn't mean it's not
incredibly personal
i mean i have i have been trying this is
the thing i mean this it's everyone has
their own approach i don't like to write
about myself explicitly
i don't feel like it's necessary um but
everyone's free to do whatever they feel
i mean
sure i mean i i incorporate parts of my
life and anecdotes into my writing but i
give it to someone else
and then that's my approach